[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من غرفتي اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم على واقع
استمرار المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع الخارجيه السعوديه تعلن
التوصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار مودته
24 ساعه والجيش السوداني يعلنه الالتزام
بالهدنه الجديده مع احتفاضه بحق التعامل
مع اي خروق قد يرتكبها المتمردون حسب وصف
اسرائيل تقول ان لبنانيين حاولوا تخريب
حاجز حدودي وتؤكد انها لن تسمح باي خلق
لسيادتها الجيش اللبناني ينفذ انتشارا في
المنطقه الحدوديه بكفر الشوبه في مواجهه
القوات الاسرائيليه وليونفيلد تحث كل
الاطراف على استخدام اليات التنسيق لمنع
حدوث خروقات وللحفاظ على استقرار جنوب
لبنان
في سابقه هي الاولى لرئيس امريكي سابق
توجيه لائحه اتهام فيدراليه
من بينها الاحتفاظ بوثائق سريه وعرقله
العداله الرئيس السابق يمثل امام القضاء
الثلاثاء المقبل ويقول ان لائحه الاتهام
تمثل تدخلا على اعلى المستويات في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الحاليه السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يقدم نجمه الفرنسي كريم بنزيما الى
الجماهير في حفل كبير في ملعب الجوهره
المشعه حيث احتشرت جماهير النادي واستعرض
امامهم جائزه الكره الذهبيه لافضل لاعب في
العالم التي حصل عليها من قبل الى اللقاء